volot medellin peu fou
défilé de volontaires à la ligue des
yvelines de tennis pour chargées dans le
camion de la société coved spécialisée
dans le traitement et la valorisation
des déchets cinquante six mille balles
usagées des balles récoltés depuis le
mois de novembre dans près de 120 clubs
du département pour l'opération balle
jaune lancé par la fédération française
de tennis
ça fait trois ans que on suit en suisse
cette opération et on a de plus en plus
d'adhérents qui spontanément viennent
nous apporter leurs balles usagées pour
la bonne cause la bonne cause le
recyclage des balles jaunes plutôt que
de finir en jouets pour chiens ou
incinérés dans le circuit traditionnel
des déchets leur seconde vie ça va être
d'être utile à nouveau c'est à dire de
dettes broyer d'être transformée pour
devenir en fait des granulats de
caoutchouc que l'on va séparer de la
feutrine et qui vont servir mélangé à de
la résine de polyuréthane à refaire des
surfaces de sports qui vont permettre de
faire de la rééducation motrice pour les
polyhandicapés de faire des terrains de
sport adapté et d'être en fait des
surfaces qui amortissent en fait le choc
six structures en ile de france ont
accueilli un sol de balle jaune recyclés
comme la maison de marie à poissy un
centre de rééducation de jeunes adultes
polyhandicapés ou une aire de 162 mètres
carrés a été installée en extérieur pour
cette année la ligue des yvelines de
tennis n'a pas encore déterminé quel
établissement bénéficiera de l'opération